[Music]
hey guys so we recently went to apple
picking and you saw on our Channel where
we went to this Orchard and it was so
much fun we got to actually pick apples
straight from the branch and put them
directly into this bag which I have in
front of me there's all these fresh
delicious apples straight from the tree
that we selected we've been eating them
just like by themselves and oh my
goodness they are delicious I know that
these aren't like the best kind of
apples to bake with like there's
different apples for for baking and
stuff and these are like more for eating
not really baking but we're gonna try to
make an apple pie with these because I'm
in a baking mood I don't know it's
really late by the way baby sleeping
Casey's helping me film this you chose
the 11 P.M to make an apple pie yes this
is a late night attempt I mean this is
really the only time we can do anything
when the baby's sleeping like at night
and he did go to sleep hours ago but
anyway the point is we're making apple
pie from scratch so pie crust is first
[Music]
flower I've been baking a lot
dang one teaspoon seems like a lot this
is a teaspoon yeah it's a teaspoon
[Music]
it's kind of fun
never cubed up butter before I like how
they feel too
oh my goodness this is difficult I'm
gonna break my Fork
what the heck they make it look so easy
[Music]
not easy because they were specific too
they were like the butter needs to be
cold
my shoulder hurts
[Music]
okay
this is a lot better
[Music]
okay now we wait a whole hour you
getting tired yet I am tired but I
committed to this and I ain't no quitter
so it's currently 11 30.
it'll take a whole hour right so 12 30
is when that should be done
oh my gosh we're not sleeping tonight
all right so since we have to wait for a
whole hour I do want to snack on these
delicious trail mix so shout outs to
toodaloo for sponsoring today's video oh
my goodness you guys you must try this
trail mix so first of all I've heard of
Toodaloo because of the owner Katie
she's like a super environmental loving
climate change tackler kind of girl like
I read her whole story and I'm like oh
my God I can't wait to try this trail
mix so what she does is she creates
these adaptogenetic trail mix and she
has four different flavors there is slow
your roll which is my personal favorite
oh my God it's so good look there is
actual so this is a Sweet Maple mix the
sprouted nuts seeds chewy super fruits
coconut reishi which by the way the
chewy super fruits there's apples in
here so it goes with the whole theme of
tonight with making apple pie and this
also supports relaxation
oh my God
it's the best it literally has like that
full nutty taste but also with the Sweet
Maple and the coconut and could really
taste it just really amplify your senses
such a big fan of this one for me I have
really been looking for healthier snacks
especially for my household you know
Casey's always really health conscious
it kind of turned me into a very
health-conscious person where I'm
constantly worried about like ways or
too much sugar in there is there's like
which is funny that I'm making an apple
pie that does have sugar in it but for
the most part we do try to be very
mindful of what we put in our bodies
that's why when I found out about
toodaloo I got really excited because
I'm like oh my God this is perfect to
just pack in in my purse and just have a
snack a healthy snack ready to go like
for whenever we're doing outings like
whenever Isaac's hungry or later on when
Luca starts snacking I don't know I'm a
really big fan I highly highly highly
recommend you guys try it and if you
guys don't love it toodaloo will give
you a refund if you're not loving their
trail mix so make sure to check out the
link down below at toodaloo.com Tiff
case to get five dollars off your first
purchase each ridiculously tasty flavor
benefits your body in a different way so
choose your favorite flavor and benefit
from skin Health digestion Focus or
relaxation like I said my personal
favorite is slow your roll but honestly
hot to trot is amazing too if you love
chocolate literally every single flavor
at Tula offers I'm such a big fan I need
to stock up the pantry with more because
these are already all gone in our
household
okay so I just finished peeling all the
apples
now we're gonna start slicing them
[Music]
thank you Casey help me behind the
scenes nice and thin
so 3 4 cups
[Music]
that damn it's a lot of sugar yeah maybe
I should have added some sugar huh and
then just let the sugar from the Apple
because these are really sweet apples
should I just try to dig out some sugar
we'll see you next time I feel like it
will be too sweet who's that flower
[Music]
[Music]
it's not good a quarter teaspoon of
nutmeg
smells like
Thanksgiving this is what you're gonna
be making for Thanksgiving this is your
practice wrong we gotta go apple picking
again
just kidding The Season's gonna be over
I love it means not smile like that
really smile you just smile a certain
way after you make a bunny
how do I mix this
[Music]
hard okay I need a man a man please I
need I need on my hands
I feel like it needs more cinnamon
I'm like I feel like it's not cinnamony
enough these are my baking instincts
kicking in right here the baker within
is like
[Music]
shall we taste
[Music]
actually I don't think yeah pretty good
kind of rock hard
okay
I only had your hands framed up and I
could tell you were thinking the way you
were like yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that should have been the bottom crust
oh that looks so good now this is the
part actually without snowing yes with
the little the bird yeah go get a bird I
know I need a bird I got a fork when I
originally thought about doing an apple
pie I was like oh I'm gonna do like this
like live like this with the strips and
like weave it that's a lot of work but
then I'm like it's 1 30 in the morning
maybe I should
that ambitious I just bit my canker sore
I heard that too
how satisfying
your bird yeah my little bird I wonder
if it's down
pan has like wider handles on the edges
so you can like hang on to it so it's
gonna have like a wider crust
[Music]
we go all right
[Music]
I can't wait
it'll be ready at three in the morning
just in time for breakfast yep apple pie
for breakfast
so ignore this side
and it's 2 30 in the morning so we're
just gonna
try it in the morning good night
look at that apple pie all right so it
is now the next day and I went to sleep
exactly as you saw me last night didn't
change didn't take off my makeup didn't
even get my hair off this ponytail but
anyway we just reheated the apple pie so
we're not gonna get to try it fresh
unfortunately it was just way too late
last night we couldn't hang
um but here we go the last shot I
recorded last night was just like yeah
he was delirious I actually left the
camera on so the battery luckily we have
another battery yeah
oh my goodness but anyway we're here we
accomplished what we came to do this is
my first apple pie so I'm really excited
yeah this is the most homemade
experience of an apple pie I've ever had
pick the apples yeah made the dough from
scratch and maybe I made this Donut from
scratching and assembled it and
everything that's so true you know I
went to sleep last night too thinking
about the filling and how I just dumped
all the apples in there but I I really
like my OCD really wanted to lay them
all beautifully like Ratatouille
yeah
this is not going to come out pretty
it's an apple cobbler how about that I
know
I know oh actually it did come out
pretty there you go oh that's pretty wow
look up like his music DJ Luke over
there
cutie pie hey cutie pie get it yeah just
kidding look at that that's my pie look
at that
oh my God that's really good I want no
secret actually don't like apple pie all
the apple pie I've ever tasted like the
apple slices are just too thick even the
one that we had at the orchard it's just
like too thick or like too sweet this is
kind of sweet actually it's very good I
should have scaled back on the sugar
yeah I've just never been a fan but I'm
really glad that we cut these um apple
slices super thin no dough is actually
really good like the pie crust there's
better than storage and even like the
the pie places I'm like is it better
than other places too it's not too sweet
this is the kind of pie and the kind of
sweetness level where
I can eat the whole thing you don't get
any butter although your favorite
Spanish words
I guess is in English
man I'm really proud of myself good job
what are you up to we did it I wish you
guys could taste this this came out
really good Thanksgiving
you're gonna be making this again
we gotta get the apples you gotta go
pick them again
pick them I think this pie is as good as
it is because of the apples that we have
[Music]
I know
oh look at him though
he's looking at the cat
that's cute that's the new tradition
we're gonna go apple picking every year
I'll make this apple pie over here yeah
I wonder what what it would tastes like
fresh we have to make another one
tonight at 2AM we're gonna make another
one
to do ice cream later tonight though
with it because uh I love apple pie a la
mode yeah that's his favorite
specifically apple pie Alla mode every
year for Thanksgiving every time I go to
Dallas he's always like trying to buy an
apple pie at the grocery store get a
pint of Blue Bell baby Bell Blue Bell I
always get them mixed up one is cheese
one is ice cream the ice cream
Bluebell and
I've never liked it I'm like that's all
you every year but if I make my own pie
then maybe I'll join you all right guys
thank you so much for watching us create
this wonderful Masterpiece of a homemade
pie from apples picked by the family
came out delicious I wish you could try
it in case we're rich now and Isaac too
yeah and Luca too Luca too we gotta add
Luca and our banner and Luca too Isaac
too and Luca also
all right guys see you next time bye
well well well what do we have here look
at this I made a way prettier pie
because the first pie was gone into
Jiffy hopefully this one comes out just
as good I also forgot to do the egg wash
on this one I made three of these little
mini ones with the extra filling that I
had an extra pie crust
[Music]